herr schön dass er dabei seine zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema chaos in
kabul wer kommt überhaupt noch raus aus
afghanistan
die lage hat sich zugespitzt die stan
die szenen die wir heute sehen am
flughafen der hauptstadt scheint noch
dramatischer zu sein tausende menschen
versuchen das land zu verlassen und das
scheint nach wie vor sehr sehr schwer zu
sein an uns erreichen nachrichten von
afghanen und afghaninnen die todesangst
haben das sind oft leute die zuvor mit
deutschland zusammengearbeitet haben und
sich nun vor den taliban fürchten so
auch so auch osmann mit dem wir gestern
hier in dieser sendung gesprochen haben
viele fühlen sich im stich gelassen und
auch verraten und wir wollen heute
sprechen über die situation am flughafen
vor ort in afghanistan in kabul mit
einer deutschen die dort fest sitzt denn
offensichtlich scheint es auch für
menschen mit ausländischen pässen nach
wie vor sehr schwer zu sein das land zu
verlassen und wir wollen einordnen und
haben fragen unter anderem auch an die
spd bundestagsabgeordnete aydan özoguz
sie ist mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss und an thomas ruttig von der
organisation afghanistan analysts
network und wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt dann könnt ihr sie
jederzeit gerne stellen entweder direkt
im chat im stream da wo er unterwegs
seid oder auch sonst wie immer gerne per
mail und wir haben im vorfeld dieser
sendung mit eben einer deutschen in
afghanistan gesprochen
wir mussten das vor aufzeichnen wir
werden außerdem auch ihren namen aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht nennen sie war
zu besuch in afghanistan und dann ging
plötzlich alles ganz schnell und sie kam
nicht mehr raus und diese szenen hier
vom flughafen in kabul davon wird sie
uns am besten schildern können denn sie
hat es auch heute wieder versucht an den
flughafen zu kommen wir haben sie zuvor
per telefon erreicht
wir erreichen nun eine deutsche in
afghanistan
die seit tagen versucht das land zu
verlassen und aus sicherheitsgründen
werden mir ihren namen jetzt hier nicht
nennen aber wir können mit ihr sprechen
und deswegen hallo schön dass du dir
zeit für uns nimmst in dieser
schwierigen zeit
hallo guten tag und jetzt kommst du
gerade hast du uns eben gerade erzählt
erneut vom flughafen was hast du da
erlebt
genau wir haben uns jetzt heute zum ich
weiß nicht zum fünfmal glaube ich auf
dem weg zum flughafen begeben
diesmal zum zug
anscheinend dass wir haben wir die
nachricht bekommen dass da anscheinend
geht offen ist das war aber nur pures
chaos aus einer riesigen menschenmenge
wie es uns überhaupt nicht ermöglicht
haben da überhaupt durchzukommen wir
haben das ja auch gestern erlebt beim
militär flughafen am nord geht das war
die information die wir vom auswärtigen
amt erhalten hatten dass wir uns da
begeben sollen und wir haben da gestern
wenn man nicht über
78 stunden verbracht um und haben glaube
ich dreimal versucht durch die
menschenmenge durchzukommen um ans ziel
zu gelangen und das war einfach
unmöglich weil die menschenmenge sehr
groß war und
schüsse gefallen sind von den soldaten
wie auch
sogenannte braucht granaten in die menge
geworfen haben und die menge auf ja
extrem
extrem war einfach zu zeiten wo ich
angst hatte ich wir ersticken oder oder
sie werden hier in nizza trampe größe
und haben das dann irgendwann aufgegeben
nach dem dritten versuch du hast eben
soldaten angesprochen über welche
soldaten reden wir da und sind auch die
taliban check points für euch ein
problem
also am geht also am nord geht waren
gestern
us-soldaten und
und später haben sie dann sind sie dann
abgezogen und haben dann afghanischer
soldaten hingestellt deutsche soldaten
haben wir gestern nicht gesehen die
waren anscheinend heute da aber wir
haben es halt nicht bis zum geht
geschafft weil einfach der weg bis dahin
komplett überfüllt war also irgendwie
anscheinend ganz kabel irgendwie hin und
nach aus kabul wegzukommen und
gerd und der weg der weg zum flughafen
zu hause haus war eigentlich überhaupt
nicht problematisch also wir haben alle
waren gesehen wir sind aber tatsächlich
so komisch das auch klingt überhaupt gar
kein problem gewesen also wir haben sich
eher mehr uns verkehr gekümmert dass die
autos durchkommen und so weiter aber es
waren jetzt also wir haben jetzt
zumindest
bei den main wo er zum flughafen
gefahren sind keine taliban checkpoints
erlebt was auch heute beim camp sullivan
da haben die uns nicht durchgelassen
haben sie tatsächlich dann das ganz
kontrolliert und
ja wir sind dann eigentlich auch nicht
durchgekommen baller einfach los war das
bekommt ihr irgendwelche hilfe aus
deutschland oder informationen mit wegen
seid ihr da in kontakt genau also wir
haben ein es gibt vom auswärtigen amt
eine e mail adresse die wir erhalten
haben also wir haben uns beim
auswärtigen amt gemeldet stehen auch auf
deren über die jungs plan oder liste
bekommen stand e mails
was wir mitnehmen dürfen und wo wir hin
sollen aber sind tatsächlich komplett
neuer standard e mails auf
einzelne anfragen wird eigentlich nicht
reagiert es gibt auch eine whatsapp die
eigentlich überhaupt nicht hilfreich ist
also ich würde eher sagen wir sind eher
viel mehr auf uns gestellt wir haben
auch jetzt versucht über die sozialen
medien andere deutsche und habe zu
finden und haben uns mit den platz und
untersuchen zum untereinander
informationen auszutauschen weil die
infos tiger vom auswärtigen amt bekommen
leider sehr für später zu uns am ja sehr
verspielt verschickt werden das
ist wer die infos bekommen ist zum
beispiel jetzt irgendwie wenn ein geht
offen ist
sind da schon irgendwie tausend andere
menschen da gestern bekommen wir die
infos vom auswärtigen amt also das ist
sehr hilfreich
ich würde sagen ich fühle mich ein
bisschen auch ein bisschen im stich
gelassen weil er mehrmals eigentlich
schon an das auswärtige amt kontaktiert
haben was die anfragen werden erstens
nicht beantwortet aber auch solche
anfragen
es ist es nun mal einfach
lebensbedrohlich dahin zu kommen also
nicht ja weg dahin zum flughafen aber
wenn man angeht ist und ich habe die
ganze zeit mein pass hoch gehalten dass
man sieht und ich hab den deutschen pass
wieso lassen sie schauen sich einfach
nur an und
dass sie einfach in die menge schießen
da sind extrem viele frauen gewesen ganz
viele kinder tragen
und so ganz das ganze geschrei und das
kann man sich kaum vorstellen dass also
wie die situation einfach da ist man und
sagst du dich sicher zur zeit in kabul
also wie fühlt sich das für dich zur
zeit an in der stadt
ja also ich bin also zu hause fühle ich
mich sicher
draußen jetzt auch in der stadt ich weiß
nicht draußen aber meine schwägerin sie
war jetzt zum beispiel
gestern war sie mal kurz einkaufen
lebensmittel einkaufen und ich ganz
normal draußen mal wieder rein und meint
irgendwie überhaupt gar kein problem
das ist es ist es ist sehr komisch
also auch im auto wo wir jetzt am auto
waren ich saß hinten mein mann mein
fahrer saßen vorne und taliban haben uns
einmal ganz kurz angehalten sobald die
gesehen haben dass ich im auto sitze
haben sie gesagt wo ich weitere da sitzt
er jetzt eine frau im auto
hast du das kommen sehen den einmarsch
der taliban also dass das so schnell
geht am ende
nein nein absolut nicht na also auch
alle leute die hier sind
wir sind komplett davon überrascht
worden
das ist wie schon zum kartenhaus der in
sich zusammenfällt so war das denn man
hat da die stunde von stunde gehörte was
was da jetzt interessiert ist und dass
das was in caputh also dass sie dann kam
letztendlich angenommen haben das war ja
das hat mich hat niemand vorgestellt wie
die us truppen und alle noch viel seien
vor ort also man konnte sich ja das gar
nicht vorstellen dass es überhaupt
passiert deswegen
ist das
ich habe das nicht kommen sehen
natürlich nicht sonst wären sie ja
danke dass du dir zeit genommen hast
heute für uns und für dieses gespräch
sie hat es heute nicht geschafft
rauszukommen aber einige hundert
menschen schon nach angaben des
verteidigungsministeriums hat die
bundeswehr bisher über 670 menschen nach
taschkent in usbekistan
ausgeflogen und wir sprechen nun mit der
spd bundestagsabgeordnete aydan özoguz
sie ist außerdem mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss guten abend frau ist ein abend
frau ist überrascht sie das zu hören
dass also auch menschen mit
ausländischem pass aber natürlich auch
genau so viele oder vielmehr ortskräfte
also immer noch in afghanistan in kabul
festsitzen
wir hören dass wir jetzt den ganzen tag
tatsächlich ich bekomme auch immer
wieder e-mails und sms und alle
möglichen hilferufe aufs handy wir hören
dass das sehr sehr schwierig ist dort
beim flughafen wir hatten größte sorge
dass der weg zum flughafen auch
schwierig werden würde tatsächlich wird
uns von allen möglichen stellen
berichtet dass die taliban sich
gottseidank zurückhaltend wie sie es
gesagt haben und nun ist es natürlich so
dass es chaotische zustände am flughafen
sind es sind wahnsinnig viele menschen
dorthin um irgendwie mit zu kommen und
das ist eigentlich das was ein so
betroffen macht weil ich auch immer
wieder höre von familien mit kindern von
einzelnen also das ist eine ganz
schwierige situation und ich bin froh
dass wir jetzt einige flugzeuge
herausbekommen haben in hamburg kommen
heute ein paar menschen auch an es sind
ja jetzt doch einige hundert zumindest
in taschkent das ist ja schon mal ein
stück sicherheit aber da muss natürlich
noch recht viel passieren also viele
warten einfach auf eine nachricht
die bundesregierung und die
nachrichtendienste haben die lage in
afghanistan zuvor völlig falsch
eingeschätzt und deshalb mussten sich
der bundesaußenminister maß und die
verteidigungsministerin heute auch in
bundestagsausschüssen verantworten und
wir haben dazu jetzt einen beitrag von
thomas reichert
die verteidigungsministerin hat sich
aufgeschrieben was sie öffentlich sagen
will an diesem mittag zu einer
bundeswehr mission wie es sie noch nie
gegeben hat sie liest von einem zettel
fragen zur evakuierungs mission zu ihrer
verantwortung aber beantwortet sie als
paar nicht
es ist ganz klar die bundeswehr wird so
lange wie möglich so schnell wie möglich
so viele menschen wie möglich dort
rausholen umso heftiger ist im
verteidigungsausschuss die kritik der
opposition daran dass die bundeswehr
nicht schnell genug losgeschickt wurde
an der viel zu späten hilfe für die
ortskräfte
dieses zögern dieses bürokratische
klein-klein zwischen verschiedenen
ministerien das kann und ich befürchte
das wird am ende des tages menschenleben
kosten in der tat werden wir danach
politisch das aufarbeiten und ich
schließe nicht aus dass dann auch für
den ein oder anderen minister und die
ministerin das ende eingeläutet wird am
morgen hat das kabinett beschlossen was
tatsächlich schon passiert die
bewaffnete evakuierung mit bis zu 600
bundeswehrsoldaten aus afghanistan
der bundestag muss dem nachträglich zu
stimmen jetzt herrscht also alle nach
dem mars kramp karrenbauer seehofer über
wochen so berichten insider das problem
nicht sehen wollten es ist ein
menschliches drama und katastrophe es
ist eine politische
katastrophe ist ein moralisches
scheitern des westen des westens
das auswärtige amt hat nun sein
afghanistan-beauftragten nach dover
geschickt doch die verhandlungen mit den
taliban dort werden schwierig wir haben
derzeit keine belastbaren sicherheits zu
sagen dass die taliban afghanische
staatsangehörige frei zum botschaft zu
flughafen passieren lassen zwei weitere
flüge soll es heute noch geben völlig
unklar wie viele es überhaupt zum
flughafen von kabul zu den erretten den
maschinen schaffen werden
frau usus sie sitzen im auswärtigen
ausschuss warum hat man das nicht kommen
sehen
ich glaube man muss ein bisschen
sortieren tatsächlich haben in den
letzten wochen und monaten
ungefähr 2500 leute ja visa erhalten
aber da gebe ich schon auch recht also
dieses bürokratische klein klein das ist
ja bei uns jetzt nicht erst jetzt so
sondern das haben wir ja immer mit ganz
vielen papieren die man dann nachweisen
muss also das ist schon schwierig aber
es haben leute visa erhalten
1900 sind auch in den letzten wochen
schon ausgeflogen aber und das ist
glaube ich das ganz große fragezeichen
niemand hat es kommen sehen und zwar
alle dienste auch nicht also in allen
ländern ganz offensichtlich wie es uns
dargestellt wird das kabel eingenommen
wird und dann auch noch so schnell also
dass die streitkräfte dort die wir hier
ausgebildet haben sich überhaupt nicht
wehren würden gar nichts tun würden das
hat offenbar niemand erwartet wir
natürlich auch nicht und das hat die
lage so dramatisch verschärft innerhalb
weniger stunden
und jetzt müssen wir auf der einen seite
ja zunächst mal wirklich diese
evakuierung machen wirklich hilfe vor
ort leisten die menschen aus fliegen
gleichzeitig humanitäre hilfe natürlich
verstärken denn es wird dort sonst zu
einer katastrophe kommen dass es
überhaupt gar keine frage und eine
auswertung moses geben aber ich glaube
die kann man nicht in dieser stunde
machen sondern jetzt müssen wir erstmal
menschenleben retten
wir haben trotzdem dazu schon auf viele
fragen im stream zb zum beispiel möchte
ich hoffe ich spreche es richtig
ausreicht da maschinen bei youtube
wissen wer hat entschieden dass sie
wenige bis gar keine ortskräfte in
sicherheit gebracht werden also damit
auch so ein bisschen die frage wer trägt
verantwortung
also ich glaube es kann er sich jetzt
nicht in der bundesregierung aber so wie
es uns dargestellt wurde gab es keine
entscheidungen darüber dass wenig
ortskräfte irgendwohin gebracht werden
sondern das chaos ist ja relativ schnell
ausgebrochen viele sind eben zu den
flughäfen gerannt haben auch gesehen
also am montag ist glaube ich noch die
letzte turkish airlines maschine von
dort gestartet da haben dann ganz viele
die schon visa hatten sofort den weg
angetreten es gibt menschen es gab jetzt
einige hundert die hatten schon visa
haben aber offenbar auch nicht gedacht
dass da jetzt so etwas passieren würde
und sind eben noch nicht ausgereift
gewesen also man sieht wie dramatisch
sich dass dort auch entwickelt haben
muss und jetzt ging es ja darum wie kann
man in diesem ganzen chaos an die
ortskräfte überhaupt herankommen sie
haben ja teilweise versucht zum
flughafen zu kommen aber natürlich nicht
alle also sie versuchen dort hinzukommen
aber teilweise warten sie eben auch auf
nachrichten das muss vernünftig
organisiert werden und die eingänge
werden ja von amerikanern wird ein
eingang wie ich es verstanden habe
kontrolliert der andere von den
deutschen und es werden eben
unterschiedliche gruppen auch jeweils
dann herein gelassen also das ist glaube
ich noch ziemlich chaotisch ziemlich
schwierig und in der augenblicklichen
lage auch sehr gefährlich wie ich
annehme deswegen könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass sehr viele sich eben
auch nicht einfach so jetzt auf den weg
machen was wahrscheinlich auch gut ist
und sondern erstmal abwarten dass man
ihnen bescheid gibt und dass sie dann
auch hinkommen können sie haben die so
wichtigen visa die es braucht erwähnt
und da haben wir vom hauptstadtstudio
unserem hauptstadtstudio in berlin die
bestätigung bekommen dass eben im juni
scheinbar menschen aus masar i scharif
hätten evakuiert werden sollen und das
ist wohl daran gescheitert an der
bürokratie in sachen visa in sachen
pässe welches ministerium hätte da
eingreifen müssen da reagieren müssen
dass das eben nicht so kommt
ach wissen sie ich habe in meiner zeit
auch als staatsministerin für
integration ja genug kritisiert an
diesen dingen manchmal sehr langsam und
sehr schwierig agieren jetzt würde ich
sagen die lage ist wirklich sehr akut
sie ist sehr schwierig und wir wollen
menschenleben retten das heißt ich fange
jetzt nicht an einen irgendeinen
ministerium zu beschuldigen oder zu
beschimpfen ich finde wir müssen das
sehr sorgfältig aus arbeiten wir müssen
sehr sorgfältig schauen was ist da
eigentlich falsch gelaufen vor allem was
hat dann auch zu dieser katastrophalen
lage geführt aber das können wir jetzt
nicht heute abend mit so auf die
schnelle einfach machen wir haben noch
viele vielmehr fragen im stream ich
versuche so viel wie möglich natürlich
aufzunehmen dörte bei youtube möchte
gerne wissen gab es keinen notfallplan
für dieses szenario
da das war doch immerhin eine
möglichkeit dass es so kommen könnte
also so wie ich es verstanden habe sind
wirklich alle davon ausgegangen dass die
taliban zwar vorrücken das haben sie
getan und das hat man jungen auch schon
seit längerem gesehen dass sie aber eben
kabel nicht einnehmen würden dass sie
ein jahr wie auch immer so ein ring um
kabel herum machen würden aber eben
nicht in carol eindringen würden das
haben sie aber dann getan und dann kamen
halt diese note evakuierung auch unsere
botschaft wie sie ja wissen nachdem auch
die anderen botschaften dort evakuiert
wurden wurden auch unsere wurde auch
unsere botschaft evakuiert und ich
glaube das ging dann doch sehr ja alles
sehr knall auf fall und sehr schnell und
sehr
dramatisch so dass ich glaube mit der
situation hatte wirklich niemand
gerechnet also so stellt sich die
situation ja da es wurde auch nicht vor
einer solchen situation so konkret
gewarnt und was mich eben auch erstaunt
ist das
erscheint nicht nur ein problem bei uns
gewesen zu sein sondern sie wissen ja
frankreich ist jetzt dort großbritannien
ist jetzt dort belgien die niederländer
haben ein flugzeug geschickt manche
müssen dann einfach unverrichteter dinge
sozusagen wieder weg aber es scheint ein
größeres problem zu sein und den müssen
wir natürlich auf den grund gehen
wir haben zuvor in dem telefongespräch
was wir nach kabul führen konnten mit
der deutschen die dort festsitzt
erfahren erlebt dass es also auch selbst
mit einem ausländischen pass zur zeit
unmöglich scheint das land zu verlassen
also welche chancen sehen sie da
überhaupt für menschen die jetzt einen
afghanischen pass haben
ja wir haben das sehr diskutiert heute
und es ist tatsächlich so ich denke sind
auch schon einige aufgaben durchaus
dabei auf diesen flügen das wird sich
jetzt zeigen
auf jeden fall ist es ganz ganz wichtig
und dieser appell ist ja nun mehrfach
schon ausgesprochen worden und auch von
uns heute immer wieder gesagt worden
ganz besonders die ortskräfte die uns
vertraut haben die mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben die ja auch so
zu sagen ja für uns da waren die dürfen
wir jetzt auf gar keinen fall im stich
lassen wir müssen jetzt dafür sorgen
dass sie heil das land verlassen können
sofern sie es wollen aber ich denke mal
die allermeisten wollen das eben auch
dass sie in sicherheit kommen dass sie
zu uns kommen können und dass wir das
möglichst zügig jetzt auch über die
bühne bringen ich weiß dass die
organisation also ob jetzt bei der
entwicklungshilfe da sind ja viele bei
den stiftungen es gibt da ja
unterschiedliche organisationen dass
auch diejenigen die mit ihnen
zusammengearbeitet haben aus also
deutsche die mit ihm zusammengearbeitet
haben jetzt auch die kontakte zu ihnen
haben und versuchen sie sozusagen auch
von deutschland aus zu leiten das ist
zum teil wirklich mit viel angst
verbunden mit viel frustrationen das ist
glaube ich alles sehr sehr verständlich
und jetzt müssen wir aber alles darauf
setzen dass ist in auf diesem flughafen
gelände wenn es denn möglich ist so
einigermaßen geordneten verhältnissen
kommt nicht zu solchen szenen wie
gestern man weiß ja auch gar nicht wäre
eigentlich alles geschossen hat offenbar
ist die bewaffnung in afghanistan auch
in der bevölkerung recht hoch wir hoffen
natürlich dass es jetzt ruhig bleibt
dass dort wirklich die menschen und eben
auch diese ortskräfte die ja häufig eben
afghanischer herkunft und sind und
afghanische pässe haben dass die eben
jetzt auch heil von uns hierher gebracht
werden können dazu die frage frau asus
der bundesaußenminister spricht von 2500
menschen die herausgeholt worden sind
aber es sind ja noch scheinbar viel mehr
was sagen sie dazu
ja es waren diese 2500 die schon visa
bekommen haben aber es sind jetzt eben
doch noch viele menschen und ihre
familien
und ich meine da kommen wir zu diesem
punkt mit der bürokratie bei uns ist
immer kernfamilie auch im asylgesetz so
definiert dass man eben sagt das ist so
vater mutter und minderjährige kinder
jeder von uns kann sich ausmalen dass
keine mutter und kein vater jetzt die
18-jährige tochter oder den 19-jährigen
sohn dort zurücklassen können oder
wollen oder dies überhaupt tun würden
das heißt wir müssen natürlich auch
diesen familienbegriff an dieser stelle
etwas erweitern das ist eben das wo man
sagt wenn ich das kann man auch ein
bisschen schneller hinbekommen kriegen
wir jetzt gott sei dank hoffentlich wohl
auch hin wie ich das verstanden habe
aber dadurch kommen wir natürlich zu
sehr viel mehr wir rechnen ja eher mit
10.000 menschen das ist in wahrheit ja
immer noch ich meine wir haben ja
erfahrung mit flüchtlingsbewegungen eine
durchaus eine zahl die man ja durchaus
auch mit flügen et cetera bewältigen
kann dass man sie in sicherheit bringt
andere nationen bringen ja auch menschen
dann in ihre länder die für sie
gearbeitet haben ich glaube das
kontingent der amerikaner ist noch sehr
viel größer wie ich das verstanden habe
also wir hoffen dass es die nächsten
tage vielleicht noch länger ruhig bleibt
und das ganze vielleicht sogar etwas
geordnete dann vonstatten gehen kann
eine letzte frage wenn sie das
vielleicht noch ganz kurz beantworten
könnten was raten sie denn jetzt frauen
oder menschen und in dem fall jetzt der
frau die wir am anfang unserer sendung
gehört haben die also festsetzt in kabul
also wenn ich das richtig verstanden
hatte ist sie registriert sie hat
durchaus ja ihre daten hinterlassen das
heißt sie wird kontaktiert werden es ist
schwer für mich natürlich von hier aus
kluge ratschläge zu geben aber was ich
von den anderen höre ist dass sie nicht
immer wieder einfach nur so losgehen
sollen dass es eben auch gefährlich sein
kann ich mein heute abend wird jetzt
kein flug mehr gehen das heißt man
sollte jetzt den morgigen tag abwarten
und möglicherweise eben noch mal das
auswärtige amt kontaktieren
beziehungsweise vielleicht auch uns
bescheid geben also menschen in
deutschland wir dann auch noch mal
nachfragen können sie wissen wir haben
hunderte von lastwagen viele abgeordnete
mittlerweile kontakte zu den leuten vor
ort und deshalb also es wird wirklich
sehr hart daran gearbeitet der
krisenstab tagt ich glaube durchgehend
im auswärtigen amt und auf diese art und
weise hoffe ich natürlich auch werden
hoffentlich alle dies betrifft dann auch
ordentlich ausgeflogen werden können
danke frau usus für dieses gespräch
heute abend
ich danke ihnen auch
drei tage sind nun vergangen seit die
taliban nun wieder die herrschaft in
afghanistan übernommen haben und mein
kollege luc wahl bord hat mal für uns
zusammengefasst was jetzt in den letzten
tagen passiert das und wie die aktuelle
lage ist
in kabul starten und landen wieder
zahlreiche militärtransporter aber die
lage rund um den flughafen ist nach wie
vor chaotisch tausende afghanen
versuchen weiter auf das gelände zu
gelangen der zugang wird von us soldaten
bewacht die auch waren schüsse abfeuern
in sozialen medien werden bilder von
verzweifelten frauen verbreitet die um
einlass bitten eine niederländische
maschine musste ohne passagiere
abfliegen weil die familien vor den
toren festhängen und an den straßenzügen
zum flughafen haben taliban kräfte
kontrollpunkte eingerichtet in anderen
vierteln der hauptstadt herrscht mehr
ruhe die menschen klagen aber über
rasant steigende preise
ein sack mehl kostet jetzt umgerechnet
20 dollar ein kanister öl 14 dollar dass
es zu viel
im südafghanischen kandahar traf
unterdessen der politische führer der
taliban mullah baradar mit einem
militärflugzeug aus katar ein baradar
gilt als möglicher chef einer
übergangsregierung
über deren bildung berieten in kabul
führende taliban mit ex präsident karzai
sowie den bisherigen regierungschef
abdullah im ostafghanischen jalalabad
kam es zu schweren protesten gegen die
machtübernahme der taliban
demonstranten trugen einen tag vor dem
unabhängigkeitstag jubeln die
afghanische flagge durch die straßen die
die taliban überall entfernt hatten
taliban- kräfte
das feuer auf die menge augenzeugen
berichten von mindestens drei toten und
einem dutzend verletzten
wir sprechen nun mit thomas ruttig vom
afghanistan analysts network aan der
politischen
forschungsorganisation vor ort guten
abend herr
und ich sie haben immer noch viele
kolleginnen und kollegen vor ort
vielleicht aber zunächst mal die frage
bevor wir über ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen auch dort sprechen und wie es
denen geht zunächst mal die frage haben
sie das kommen sehen dass das so schnell
ging und die taliban aus kabul über
nehmen konnten
das ist so schnell gehen wie es gegangen
ist das hat wohl kaum jemand
vorausgesehen aber dass die taliban
kabul übernehmen könnten und würden war
im gegensatz zu dem was du vorher gehört
haben im bereich des möglichen und das
auch
vorausgesagt worden durch die
einschätzung des us geheimdienstes
was ja auch eigentlich der
bundesregierung und parlamentarierinnen
bekannt sein sollte
überraschender effekt auch schon dabei
und man hat sich darauf einstellen muss
ich meine notfallszenarien müssen auch
greifen wenn etwas schneller geht als
man es eigentlich erwartet
und wie geht es zurzeit also all jenen
vor ort die für sie arbeiten konnten die
ausreisen wenn sie das gewollt hätten
können die überhaupt noch arbeiten wie
es das
ja ich werde jetzt gar nicht in die
einzelheiten gehen wir sind noch dabei
unseren mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern dort unten zu helfen den
meistens und noch nicht aus dem land im
moment haben wir die arbeit im land
eingestellt unser büro abgeschlossen und
versuchen das von außen erstmal weiter
zu tragen was auch möglich ist wir
stehen ja aus afghanischen und nicht
auch keine schönen mitarbeiterin
gibt ja auch immer wieder die frage also
oder es heißt immer wieder man muss auf
sogenannten listen stehen also wer nicht
draufsteht hat ein großes problem wissen
sie darüber mehr können sie darüber auch
mehr sagen ja das ist richtig die
verschiedenen regierungen die in
afghanistan vertreten waren muss man
jetzt sagen waren es gibt ihn nur noch
botschafts vertretung auf dem flughafen
dort haben ihren bürgerinnen und bürgern
die dort sind den trotz kräften und auch
einigen anderen gesagt wie man sich dort
registrieren kann das hat sich ja nicht
alle erreicht was mit dem angerichteten
chaos und der viel zu späten reaktion zu
tun hat aber wir haben auch erfahren mit
verschiedenen ländern dass es nachher
eigentlich sehr gut organisiert ist wir
müssen unterscheiden zwischen der lage
direkt auf dem flugplatz und außerhalb
des flugplatzes wir haben hier in diese
menschenaufläufe gesehen auch gesehen
dass taliban in die luft geschossen
haben
die kontrollieren die zufahrt zum
flughafen zum zivilen teil es sollen ja
auch wieder zivile flüge stattgefunden
haben in einer stadt wie vorher auch
gesagt worden ist auch wenn der
augenzeugen in kabul herrscht weitgehend
ruhe da gibt es auch keine taliban
kontrollpunkte die gucken ob man zu den
autos rein was auch bedrohlich sein kann
aber jetzt nicht wirklich sehr schlimmes
und den flughafen selbst kontrolliert
das amerikanische militär und die geben
dort slots also ein flugzeit punkte an
die verschiedenen staaten mit ihren
flugzeugen die natürlich relativ kurz
sind wo man leute aufladen muss und man
muss dann vorher halt gut organisiert
sein und die leute die man mitnehmen
möchte dann schon auf dem flughafen
haben sonst geht nicht wir haben auch
nicht gehört dass die taliban leute
zurückhaltend dann dorthin zukommen
lassen sie uns auch mal über die taliban
sprechen wie die sich also zur zeit
verhalten wir haben also dazu auf fragen
im stream nie werde ich gleich auch noch
mit aufnehmen aber wie erleben sie das
also aktuellen die taliban im umgang mit
der bevölkerung vor ort
ja schon seit mehreren jahren haben die
taliban versucht sich hier in ihrem
herangehen an die bevölkerung und wie
sie mit ihnen im alltag umgehen zu
mäßigen wir alle kennen ja noch die
geschichten und die bilder aus der
ersten taliban herrschaftszeit bis 2001
als die frauen zum großen teilen aus dem
sozialen leben aus dem arbeitsleben
verdrängt waren das sehr schwierig waren
bildung heranzukommen es gab zwar
mädchen die noch zur schule gehen was
man meistens wollen ausländischen und
afghanischen nichtregierungsorganisation
organisiert manchmal auch im
zusammenarbeit oder mit duldung
bestimmter teile band funktionäre es
gibt ja auch immer unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen dem versuchen jetzt
entgegen zu gehen denn vor 2001 haben
die sind die taliban letztendlich daran
gescheitert natürlich das erstmal die
anschläge des 11 septembers in
afghanistan ausgeben auch wenn sie
selber die nicht organisiert haben aber
sie haben eben al qaida
herbert geboten und dann haben sich die
globalen schon vorher von hinternah zwar
gemeinschaft isoliert einfach auch durch
über menschenrechtsverletzungen und
durch ihre unterdrückungspolitik gerade
in frauen gegenüber und damit natürlich
auch vor allem von der afghanischen
bevölkerung das zählt ja die wollen sie
jetzt regieren und so fahren sie an
etwas gemäßigter zu sein aber wir müssen
noch abwarten ob es da fortschritte gibt
und selbst wenn es fortschritte gibt
muss man auch sagen haben sie noch lange
nicht den standard erreicht den man
eigentlich von einer regierung erwarten
kann eines landes das auch mitglied der
uno wester gibt es bestimmte
festlegung und werte und konventionen
und verträge an die sich auch die
taliban halten müssen ansatz müssen aus
der eu austreten es gibt auch viele
überraschungen stream also was heißt
überraschung aber es gibt also auch
stimmen die sind auch davon überrascht
waren dass die taliban ist also so
einfach hatten es im land wieder die
kontrolle zu übernehmen beispielsweise
baron baron owetschkin fragt sich waren
die afghanischen streitkräfte komplett
durchsetzt von taliban kämpfern
nein das war gar nicht das hauptproblem
ich glaube schon dass oder wir haben
erkenntnisse darüber natürlich dass die
taliban noch ihre informanten und leute
hatten neulich gab es ein video in den
sozialen medien beschrieb eine ehemalige
afghanische mitarbeiterin der
hilfsorganisation
ach ist doch meine ehemaliger kollege
der walder inzwischen als
taliban-kommandeur zugange solche sachen
gibt es auch aber es waren zwei faktoren
die die streitkräfte zum zusammenbruch
geführt haben dass eine der
bedingungslosen abzug von einem
amerikanischen aber unser truppen das
ist zum teil über nacht passiert die
amerikaner haben zum beispiel auf ihrem
hauptstützpunkt ohne ihren afghanischen
kollegen bescheid zu sagen ein teil
meiner am licht gehabt der 20 minuten
nachdem ihr letztes flugzeug abgehoben
hat automatisch ausgegangen und die
afghanen heimlich gewinner wohl die alle
geblieben sind nicht viel anders war es
auch mit den deutschen das haut
natürlich jemanden moralisch die die
beine weg wenn man bis dahin als partner
und auch als ausbildungs
haubner gesehen worden ist und dazu kam
dass die tage waren einfach sehr clever
waren und schon über monate wenn nicht
jahre
kontakte aufgebaut haben auch zu den
örtlichen zivilen verwaltungen zu den
militärkommandeure zur bevölkerung den
stammesältesten sogar zu den müttern der
afghanischen soldaten und haben die
beeinflusste ihren söhnen in diesem fall
zu sagen ihre jobs bei der armee einfach
liegen zu lassen und sich jetzt nicht in
thale waren entgegen zu stellen also ihr
leben zu retten und es nicht zu
riskieren und das hat funktioniert und
dann gab es einen domino prinzip
sozusagen
200 der 400 distrikten afghanistans sind
innerhalb von zwei monaten haben sie
gefallen und das ist auch genau der
punkt warum uns eigentlich hatte kommen
sehen was am ende auch kabul fallen
könnte das war mai und juni man hätte
vorbereitet sein können das haben wir
jetzt schon in zwei antworten betont
dass ich dann noch mal nachfragen hat
dann zb auch ihre organisation da auch
im vorfeld vielleicht auch schon
öffentlich darauf aufmerksam gemacht es
ihnen da vielleicht auch sonst sind in
der viele infos darüber aufgefallen die
man hätte wählen können müssen ja wir
sind ja eine politische analyse
organisation wir haben natürlich darüber
schon seit langen geschrieben wir haben
sehr genau analysiert als die
nordafghanische provinz stadt kunduz
2015 und 16 zum ersten mal fiel das war
ja der hauptstadt sanierungs ort der
bundeswehr sehr lange und haben dort
auch auf die faktoren hingewiesen die da
eine rolle spielen also was die moral
betrifft die mangelnde bezahlung der
soldaten dass die deren sollten wir sie
unregelmäßigkeiten dass sich viele
vorgesetzte den sollte in die tasche
gesteckt haben den nicht ausgezahlt
haben das ist halt
wenn's brenzlig wurde wenig nachschub
gab das verwundete nicht ausgeflogen
worden dass man sich um die
hinterbliebenen familie nicht gemacht
hat und so weiter das hat dazu geführt
dass viele soldaten einfach die
afghanistan hatte eine vertragsklausel
polizei dreijahresverträge ihre verträge
am ende meistens nicht erneuert haben
musste im grunde alle drei jahre neuer
polizei und armee ausbilden dass und
300.000 mann und das hat einfach nicht
dass man nicht nachhaltig und ist dann
zusammengebrochen aber der hauptfaktor
war ist weder bewaffnung noch mannschaft
stark sondern ist die moral einmal dass
die alliierten sie verlassen haben und
zum zweiten natürlich auch dass die
regierung und google auch zu großen
teilen gruppe und viele leute dachten
das sind eigentlich nicht leute ich
verteilen möchte man jetzt auch selbst
wenn die taliban jetzt davon sprechen
dass sie das jetzt irgendwie sich alles
anders alles anders machen wollen als
vor 20 jahren und auch von den modernen
taliban die rede ist gibt es jedoch auch
ängstliche stimmen die sagen was ist
wenn in zwei wochen alle ausländer
draußen sind und was ist wenn dann also
auch weniger medienberichten wird sich
dann nicht alles ändern was wir schätzen
sie das ein genau das ist der punkt
diese angst das ganz große unter den
afghanen afghanen und man muss das auch
sehr sehr ernst nehmen und gleichzeitig
muss man halt dafür sorgen dass wir eben
nicht nach zwei wochen auf ihr in
afghanistan zu berichten und darauf zu
passen das liegt nicht nur an die medien
wie zum beispiel auch an den vereinten
nationen die in afghanistan sind die
taliban haben wir wohl nur gesagt bleibt
bitte hier die denkt natürlich vor allen
dingen an die humanitären hilfswerke sie
haben ja auch ihre ersten
pressekonferenz auch gesagt dass sich
der drogenbekämpfung der an der
bekämpfung des drogenanbaus widmen
wollen da brauchen natürlich dann geld
um alternative kulturen anbauen zu
können also die die leute die bauern
afghanistans ja zu großen teilen ein
agrarland und da muss man sie packen man
kann jetzt von ihnen denken was man will
sie sind da man muss mit ihnen arbeiten
es gibt 80 prozent der bevölkerung lebt
unter der armutsgrenze
auch die taliban müssen die irgendwie
ernähren und dazu brauchen sie
auswärtige hilfe und das muss man eben
auch als hebel und als druckpunkt
einsetzen um das schlimmste zu
verhindern ich erwarte nun nicht dass
die taliban sich irgendwie in
afghanischer grüne verwandeln und auf
einmal
sozusagen über alle werte vertrag
vertreten und könnte es aber deshalb
auch sein dass sie jetzt also schon die
menschen jetzt eher nicht daran
behindern an diesem check points vorbei
zum flughafen zu kommen oder ist das nur
spekulation genau sehe ich auch so die
sind daran interessiert wollen erstmal
die alte regierung was dann noch übrig
ist und deren polizei und so weiter zu
entwaffnen das ging relativ schnell ein
zwei tage dann hatten wir die 19
polizeireviere von google übernommen
wann haben eigenen gouverneur eingesetzt
und so weiter ansonsten halten sich
zurück konnte
weitgehend man muss natürlich auch sagen
dass berichte kommen dass die taliban
haben auch im geheimdienst der es darum
geht und leute besucht die sie einfach
auf der auf offenbar auf listen haben
von denen sie wissen dass sie kritisch
berichtet haben oder kritisch stellung
genommen haben dass sie möglicherweise
auch zu politischen gegnern werden
könnten es gibt keine bestätigten
berichte nur sehr wenige haftungen
gegeben hatte manchmal kommen leute auch
wieder relativ raus aber es ist
natürlich auch eine relativ schnell raus
aber es ist natürlich auch eine art von
einschüchterung die da versucht wird um
überhaupt erst mal keine opposition oder
abweichende meinung aufkommen zu lassen
wir wissen dass man untersuchungen in
den vielen gebieten digital japanischen
über jahre
kontrollieren dass er natürlich von
surrealismus und meinungsfreiheit
überhaupt keine rede sein kann jeder der
eine politische andere meinung hat musst
du den mund halten und läuft sonst
gefahr wirklich im sinne des wortes von
intel avant verdroschen zu werden wenn
nicht mehr
und wichtig ist jetzt dass auch die
internationale staatengemeinschaft
werden die evakuierung vorbei ist ja
eben eine worauf funktion da unten
behält und intel waren auch die klinger
sid
wie groß schätzen sie denn die gefahr
für die ortskräfte tatsächlich ein also
es gibt ja auch welche die sagen na ja
da wird schon nichts schlimmeres
passieren also da vielleicht noch mal
gezielt jetzt auf diese ortskräfte die
auch mit deutschland zusammengearbeitet
haben in was für einer gefahr schweben
die oder vielleicht auch ist sie gar
nicht so groß na ja zu sagen vielleicht
passiert dann nix oder hoffentlich
passiert da nichts das natürlich nichts
worauf man der politik basieren kann
dann gibt es eine verantwortung den
westen bis zu großen teilen für die
misere also die machtübernahme der die
erneute machtübernahme der taliban nach
25 jahren verantwortlich und muss sich
um die leute kümmern die mit ihm und für
ihn gearbeitet haben und auch die leute
die sich engagiert haben für demokratie
und menschenrechte
das sind sehr viel mehr als die
ortskräfte aber die deutsche regierung
hat sich von anfang an sehr hartleibig
gezeigt sie hatten ja vorhin die frage
welche im ministerium zuständig oder
verantwortlich sind für diese
verzögerung jetzt endlich alle vier die
nachfrage stetig mal im
verteidigungsministerium
innenministerium über die polizei
mission auswärtiges amt und vor allem
auf das bmz das entwicklungsministerium
bundesminister für wirtschaftliche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und bnz haben
über wochen und monate gesagt ja wir
wollen ja weiter arbeiten er selbst wenn
die taliban an die macht kommen und so
leute sind nicht in gefahr das problem
ist aber dass auch deutsche staatliche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ja oft
zusammen mit der bundeswehr gemacht
wurde und die bundeswehr an einem krieg
und die taliban haben alles was die
bundeswehr gemacht hat also auch
entwicklungsprojekte
als sozusagen kampfhandlungen quasi
kampfhandlung angesehen das stück doch
man hat ja versucht den taliban
unterstützung abzugraben an dem man
bevölkerungs
bestimmte bevölkerungsteile auch mit
entwicklungsprojekten ich sage jetzt an
anführungsstrichen zu bestechen oder auf
die eigene seite zu ziehen da haben sie
natürlich dagegen gehalten in dem krieg
ist das leider so insofern muss man
wirklich alle vier ministerien fragen
und besonders auch die zu ihren
ministerien interessanterweise auch das
verteidigungsministerium hat sich nicht
mit ruhm bekleckert hat nur die
ortskräfte erst aus fliegen wollen in
den letzten zwei jahren noch flüssig
gearbeitet haben man hat dann relativ
schnell dort ein bisschen nachwuchs noch
aber zb gab es viele firmen afghanische
deutsche drittländer firmen die auch auf
dem bundeswehrstützpunkt gearbeitet
haben diese leute obwohl die quasi im
selben verhältnis zur bundeswehr stand
hat man das heute noch gar nicht auf
diese listen sind bei den listen
aufgenommen oder nur in ausnahmefällen
kann diese verzweifelten nachrichten
haben uns auch erreicht das hatte ich am
anfang der sendung angesprochen also für
viele menschen ist das immer noch eine
tatsächlich sehr verzweifelte situation
vor ort vielleicht zum schluss noch die
frage was ist denn ihre zukunftsaussicht
was was glauben sie was passiert wenn
man das überhaupt noch wackeln kann in
den nächsten tagen und wochen
ja ich sage immer ich bin ein analyst
keine macht ich wäre froh wenn ich
wüsste was an der nächsten woche den
ersten zwei wochen passiert
darüber hinaus ist wirklich sehr schwer
zu sagen da gibt es zwei szenarien
entweder weil die taliban wieder in
ihrer alten in ihre alte repressive
haltung zurück und dann muss man
wirklich das unternehmen oder es
passiert das was die meisten leute nicht
viele möglichkeiten dass sie tatsächlich
daran festhalten und man dann auch
weiter zusammen mit der afghanischen
bevölkerung druck auf sie ausüben muss
dass sie halt dinge zuletzt diese bis
jetzt nicht zugelassen haben zum
beispiel das mädchen in salzburg klasse
6 zur schule gehen
vielen dank thomas ruttig für diese
analyse und ihre antworten heute abend
gerne
und vielen dank auch an euch dass ihr so
fleißig im stream zugeschaut hat
kommentiert habt fragen gestellt habt
dieses thema wird uns sehr
wahrscheinlich wir haben die letzten
tage auch schon immer wieder gesagt wird
uns noch weiter beschäftigen und wir
bleiben natürlich dabei schauen drauf
und gehen dann auch jederzeit wieder
live und jetzt bis dahin danke und
tschüss